olá meu nome é júnior mais conhecido
como júnior da maximus
eu quero começar mostrando essa foto pra
vocês é uma máquina de costura antiga
uma singela é um artefato que está na
minha família há mais de 60 anos
essa máquina pertenceu a minha avó e diz
muito também sobre a minha história
agora imaginem vocês uma menininha de
apenas nove anos de idade que sentada
numa cadeira para costurar uma máquina
dessas mal alcançava a manivela
certa manhã essa menina ficou em casa
para cuidar do almoço enquanto a família
e trabalhar na roça e ela resolveu
aprontar uma das delas
ela pegou a única causa domingueira do
seu irmão mais velho e cortou bem aqui
no meio fazendo uma barrinha italiana
dobrando assim ela cria um shorts o
irmão mais velho e das pernas da calça
que ela tinha tirado ela fez uma saia de
pregas para uma das irmãs quando a minha
avó chegou em casa e viu a estripulia
ela ficou furiosa
só que ela pegou e começou a olhar mas
tinha ficado tão bem feito que aí ela
perdoou é claro e começou a ensinar tudo
o que ela sabia pra minha mãe já adulta
a minha mãe escolheu a profissão de
costureira e de costureira foi a
empresária casou-se com meu pai que por
acaso também era alfaiate e há 35 anos
mais ou menos em 1984 eles fundaram o
que hoje é o grupo max
três anos depois veio o primogênito
eu nasci em 1987 aos 14 e comecei a
trabalhar na empresa da família e com 18
meus pais se divorciaram eu já estava na
faculdade de administração e aí eu senti
que tinha chegado a minha hora
a minha hora de também empreender
entrando na empresa vive todos aqueles
dramas que os filhos de dono enfrentam
quando entra para trabalhar não me
acertei muito bem com a minha mãe no
começo mas eu gosto de uma frase que diz
os mais velhos sabem da onde o mundo
veio e os mais jovens saibam do mundo
vai
isso é ótimo essa dieta dialética só que
eu não consegui esperar o tempo
necessário
aí eu resolvi abandonar a loja sair
pra ser distribuidor independente da
herbalife
sim eu usava aquele botão dizendo assim
quer perder peso pergunte me como eu
tinha certeza que ia fazer fortuna com o
marketing multinível seis meses depois
as coisas não foram lá né como eu
esperava
coloquei o rabinho entre as pernas e
voltei pra na empresa da família mas eu
tinha uma carta na manga
eu fui lançar a revista maxim os noivos
começo também não foi fácil
tinha 19 anos essa barba não tinha
crescido ainda mais para compensar a
falta de experiência ea credibilidade
eu ia todo engravatado visitar os
anunciantes chegava um pouco antes da
hora marcada como a gente só tinha um
carro muitas vezes eu tinha que fazer as
visitas de bicicleta e engraçado que eu
tinha que colocar a barra da calça por
dentro da meia para não pegar na correia
da bicicleta mas desta vez não
prosperaria
a revista era um anuário editado apenas
uma vez por ano porém nas últimas
edições era bem recheada tinha mais 350
páginas chegou a ter 200 anunciantes por
edição e eu chegava a cobrar até dois
mil reais por uma única página de
anúncio
naquela época provavelmente o anúncio
mais caro de publicação da região
essa revista a gente também teve a
oportunidade de visitar seis países
fotografando editoriais de moda
internacional com direito a um prémio de
fotografia em paris
ela foi descontinuada dez anos depois em
2016 pelo motivo de a forte chegada das
mídias digitais
então ela deixou um grande legado é
claro que o grupo maximus nessa altura
do campeonato minha mãe já com certeza
era a estilista mais uma das estilistas
mais bem pagas do paraná
e quando a revista terminou em 2016
também se falava muito das startups
eu pensei vou fazer um aplicativo
exclusivo vai ser a ponte para aposentar
revista entrar no digital com mídia
o aplicativo se chamava bem-casados ele
era um ad planner um aplicativo para as
noivas organizar o casamento um check
list tinha planilha financeira mais uma
função que no fim das contas acabou me
custando um prejuízo de praticamente 70
mil reais porque as novas no fim não
baixavam usar né então presidente de se
continuar o projeto do aplicativo e
nessa altura do campeonato também o
grupo maximus além das lojas de locação
um dos tradicionais lojas de locação já
tinha também aberto duas lojas físicas
de tecidos uma aqui na cidade de
cascavel e uma em toledo e cascavel ia
muito bem obrigado dava lucro mais a de
toledo estava capengando a gente não
conseguia bater ponto de equilíbrio
aí eu cheguei pro meu irmão lucas não
sócio em tudo que eu tenho do
empreendimento inclusive aqui e falei
lucas ele estava arrependido já lado bem
casados que tinha dado zica ele estava
junto comigo no investimento
agora a gente vai abrir uma loja online
que vai pegar o estoque da loja física
da mãe que não está vendendo aquela lá
vai cadastrar vai comprar a câmera
fotográfica estúdio tal quanto aos 50
mil mas não agora vai dar certo
ele comprou a idéia a gente fez tudo na
escura se não controlada da minha mãe
só que ela vinha chegando máquina coisa
só no dia que o site entrou no ar
contratou plataforma de e comerce tudo
que ela foi comunicada de uma proposta
que ela não poderia recusar porque nós
assumiríamos todos os riscos e ainda que
venderia o estoque dela daria todo
dinheiro pra ela
ou seja a melhor proposta né ok ela
aceitou mas agora nessa altura da
história tem uma confissão para fazer
pra vocês até aqui eu não sabia o
propósito do negócio que eu abrir o
porquê não era claro para mim
mas aí veio um site eu gostava de fazer
curso de marketing digital e aqui na
cidade de cascavel está fazendo um curso
que a instrutora indicou um livro
transformador que eu ainda não li mas eu
indico para todos vocês porque esse
livro mudou a minha vida
o nome do livro mas vou explicar é o
nome do livro é que comece pelo porque
do autor
saibamos inec é que assim eu gosto de
ler só que como eu viajo muito e eu
tenho o hábito de escutar podcasts então
sempre que alguém me fala de um livro
que eu gosto um título eo primeiro
procure um podcast um audiobook até um
vídeo no youtube que fale do assunto e
eu achei um teste desse cara no youtube
falando comércio porque o mesmo título
né
aí eu falei assim assiste inclusive foi
muito revelador que ele falou que eu
quero mostrar pra vocês aqui ele tem
esse de golden circle que a idéia
central dele então ele tem o círculo
menor dentro porque
o como em seguida e o círculo maior o
que então ele fala que 100% das empresas
sabem o que elas fazem aqui o círculo
maior e também a maioria das empresas
sabe como elas fazem agora
pouquíssimas empresas do mundo sabem o
porquê de elas fazerem escolhas e aquilo
mexeu comigo porque a max nos tecidos
que era a menina dos olhos do e commerce
que estava montando e tudo mais que
tinha feito não tinham porque eu não
tinha essa clareza e aí eu decidi que eu
queria um propósito para nossa empresa
não podia ser qualquer propósito eu
queria um propósito nobre grandioso sabe
que valesse a pena assim como a apple
que é tipo tenho com sync diferente dela
que ela quer desafiar o status quo em
tudo que ela faz uma frase que eu gosto
da nike que disse para a nike
se você é um atleta se você tem um corpo
você é um atleta
então eu disse nós não venderemos
tecidos
nós vamos resgatar o hábito de costurar
esse vai ser o nosso propósito e veja
como a comunicação fica muito mais clara
quando a gente fala de dentro do círculo
para fora e não de fora para dentro
vamos primeiro da maneira errada quando
eu digo que eu faço vendendo tecidos
como eu faço preço justo variedade
online frete grátis entrega rápida quer
comprar comunicação fria sem sentimento
né
e se eu digo pra vocês o nosso propósito
é resgatar o hábito de costurar para
isso nós vendemos tecidos online a um
preço justo e acessível para que isso
possa difundir e chegar a todo o brasil
e aí a comunicação muda porque ela trata
de sentimento ela se conecta com as
pessoas a partir do da definição do
nosso propósito tudo passa pelo filtro
do propósito ou seja se a gente vai
contratar um funcionário novo a gente
vai lançar um novo produto a gente tem
que responder essa pergunta isso vai
levar mais adiante próximo do nosso
propósito ou vai nos distanciar desse
propósito ea partir disso a gente
começou
baile linkado com o propósito a criar
serviços e produtos que estavam
orbitando ao redor desse propósito
então hoje nós vendemos não só tecidos
livros de costura moldes e réguas cursos
online para ensinar as pessoas a
costurar
temos um blog chamado clube da
costureira que recepciona artigos das
maiores autoridades do assunto
temos o rádio da costureira é o primeiro
podcast do brasil e até onde eu sei o
único direcionado para costureiras
estilistas e amantes da moda sob medida
nós temos é conteúdo gratuito 14
patrocinamos produção de conteúdo
gratuito e mais de 50 canais no youtube
porque está linkado com o nosso
propósito
recentemente fizemos parcerias com duas
marcas exclusivas com duas marcas muito
expoente do mercado assim dizer que nada
mais é do que uma empresa centenária
presente em 150 países líder mundial na
produção de máquinas de costura e
responsável por difundir a cultura
doméstica como a gente conhece ela hoje
e ainda a revista manequim que a revista
de moda mais antigo do brasil completou
agora 60 anos também temos uma coluna lá
onde a gente apoia essa produção de
conteúdo como esse propósito definido os
resultados começaram a chegar à loja
online recém fez quatro anos mas já
conquistamos mais de 30 mil clientes
pelo brasil entregamos quase dois mil
pacotes por mês
mas eu quero falar como é que isso
funciona na prática
eu acho que não vai dar pra ler por isso
eu vou tirar o celular aqui que eu tenho
aqui eu vou dar pra vocês
apenas um exemplo de como a gente
resolve problemas de clientes da empresa
tá então aqui eu tenho um print de
conversa do nosso grupo do atlético lá
da loja
eu consigo ler aqui então a nossa
funcionária paula que é uma consultora
de moda inclusive líder do departamento
de atendimento postou aqui uma foto de
um envelope onde a gente manda os livros
pra das clientes e um livro todo rasgado
e mordido aí tem uma mensagem da cliente
reclamando seguinte olá meu nome é
gabriela acabei de comprar um livro de
vocês e ele chegou só gostaria de pedir
que retirassem a entrega como se fosse
uma carta pois o carteiro não chamou
simplesmente jogou o livro no quintal ea
minha cachorra devorou infelizmente
estou muito mal
sei que vocês não tiveram culpa mas o
livro que eu esperei tanto agora é só um
monte de papel picado e aí a nossa
colaboradora
sem pensar se é recriminado ou não e não
só trazer um problema sem uma solução
para esse problema disse sim sei
exatamente o que a cliente está sentindo
posso reenviar o livro com uma cartinha
e um brinquedinho novo cachorrinho
agora vou ler a carta escrita punho que
a nossa colaboradora fez em nome não só
dela mas de toda a equipe
agora eu acho que é preciso celular está
aqui foi gabriela
recentemente você me deu a notícia de
que a nutella comeu a sua
correspondência
sei exatamente como é isso também já foi
vítima dos dentinhos ferozes dos meus
filhinhos
nessa brincadeira já perdi números
calçados roupas sofá cantinhos de
imóveis e pasme até um pedaço do piso
mostrei a sua carta para a sua foto para
minha equipe e todos ficaram
sensibilizados a situação até seria
cômica se não fosse trágica mas como nós
somos apaixonados por dominguinhos
estamos enviando um presentinho pra
novela esperamos que ela goste e nessas
fotos estão os nossos terroristas apanha
o pico nutrição do joelho da camilla
os donos da loja eo charlie bruno são os
meus mas não se engane com essas
carinhas fofas
eles também adoram rasgar papéis com
carinho paula gomes e equipe max que a
cliente recebeu simples um mordedor foto
do nosso insossos casalzinho de paguei
meu da minha esposa camilla eo charlie o
bruno aqui do lado direito da paula é
claro um livro de volta para a cliente
não é nada mais justo então o que eu
quero dizer com isso de forma bem breve
tanto eu não recrimina o comportamento
dela quanto o estilo porque é humano
porque é uma experiência que está na era
da experiência que a gente tem um
propósito ea gente quer angariar para
que o propósito aconteça a mensagem
final
eu quero deixar para vocês quando as
pessoas reconhecem o nosso propósito
elas não compram porque nós queremos que
elas comprem ou elas não se candidata a
uma vaga apenas pelo emprego
elas fazem isso por elas mesmas
simplesmente porque elas querem
participar da causa
então se você é um empreendedor ou se
você sonha um dia em empreender
o recado que eu dou é preocupe se
primeiro com o propósito
se você não sabe a resposta da pergunta
do porquê
busque a dentro do seu coração
talvez a resposta esteja na história da
sua família comum como o meu caso eu
mostrei pra vocês do que voltou na
máquina mas o importante é que você
escolha uma causa pela qual você quer
acordar todas as manhãs para lutar por
ela
muito obrigado
[Aplausos]